صوره صادمه رسمتها اوراق البيت الابيض
السريه التي احتفظ بها الرئيس الامريكي
السابق في مرحاض وغرف نوم منزله في
فلوريدا
اوراق حملت اسرار الحكومه الامريكيه حول
برنامجها النووي وخططها العسكريه
واجازاتها الاستخباراتيه التي من المفترض
ان يتم تقاسمها فقط بين المسؤولين
الامريكيين وفق اكسيوس لكن ما فعله ترامب
بعد صدور لائحه الاتهام ضده التي شملت 37
تهمه هو الظهور مرتين في كل من جورجيا
مستانفا حملته الانتخابيه مهاجما للجميع
ومدافعا عن صورته
انتم تشاهدون كيف يحاول جو بايدن سجن
منافسه السياسي الرئيسي فكر قليلا بذلك
هذا تماما ما يفعله قاده دول العالم
الثالث الذين يفضلون سجن خصومهم بدلا من
مواجهتهم انتخابيا الامر واضح وبسيط
تهم على كثرتها طالت الرئيس الحالي جو
بايدن بدات بان بايدن يسعى لوضع ترامب
بالسجن لتجنب منافسته وصولا الى اتهامه
بتلقي اموال من الصين للاحتفاظ بصناديق
مليئه بالوثائق السريه كلمه لم يسلم منها
الا قليل طالت هنتر نجله بايدن ايضا الذي
اكد ترامب ان المكتب الفيدرالي لديه ادله
دامغه على تلقي نجل بايدن اموالا طائله من
اوكرانيا لحاكم فلوريدا رونديس نصيب وافي
من خطابه ايضا حيث وصفه ترامب بانه بلا
شخصيه ولا يستطيع الفوز في الانتخابات
القادمه
لا يزال مقتنعا بان الوثائق التي يملكها
ارشيفيه وليس سريه وبان الجهات الفيدراليه
يجب الا تشارك في محاوله اتهامه اياد حمود
العربيه
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات